Season 2 of The Mandalorian was an
Easter egg-filled extravaganza — one
that had many Star Wars fans leaping
for joy. From the return of Boba
Fett to the live-action debut of Clone Wars
favorites such as Bo-Katan and Ahsoka Tano,
the second season of The Mandalorian somehow
cleared the high bar set by the first. But if
you ask many fans about the biggest surprise
moment the second season had to offer,
they'll probably mention a certain cloaked
Jedi who makes an appearance in the finale.
In "Chapter 16, The Rescue," the Mandalorian
and his allies are pitted against a legion of
Dark Troopers, and all hope looks lost until
a young Luke Skywalker arrives on the scene,
brings down the evil droids, and takes
Grogu off for some special Jedi training.
It was easily the series' biggest moment thus
far, with Skywalker's youthful appearance
coming down to some unique technology
and a little collaboration with Mark
Hamill — the "Star Wars" legend who is
also a self professed fan of the series.
"It's very much in the spirit of what George
wanted originally, and I just thought it was
superb."
Still, although many fans loved this moment,
others were less impressed — mostly by the
execution of Skywalker's de-aging process.
Either way, we're about to learn more about the
technology that went into this cameo moment,
thanks to an upcoming Disney+
special centered around it.
Mandalorian fans may have already tuned into
the documentary series Disney Gallery: The
Mandalorian, which offers a behind-the-scenes look
at individual episodes of the show, and provides
crucial information about how each individual
story — and the series as a whole — came to
life. Now that Season 2 has run its course, most
fans assumed that The Mandalorian's Disney Gallery
series was unlikely to return until the main
show's third season. Those same people might
be surprised to learn that the House of Mouse
is bringing back its popular behind-the-scenes
docuseries well ahead of schedule, with a
fresh episode set to hit Disney+ in August.
Disney+ will premiere their special
episode of Disney Gallery on August 25th,
2021, which focuses on the return of Luke
Skywalker in the Mandalorian Season 2 finale.
Among other things, the episode will reveal more
about the type of technology used to resurrect
Luke in his classic Return of the Jedi look, as
well as examine the collaborative process with
Mark Hamill that proved essential to making
Luke's appearance as realistic as possible.
So, if you were one of the many Star Wars fans
who got a little teary-eyed at the return of
everyone's favorite Jedi master, then this new
episode of Disney Gallery will be right up your
alley. But what can we actually expect to learn
from it? Well, aside from knowing that actor Max
Lloyd-Jones was responsible for the bodywork
of young Luke, there's precious little anyone
does know about the technical and collaborative
work that went into Luke's return. It's possible
to make a reasonable guess how it all worked,
considering similar technology has been used
in previous Star Wars movies and elsewhere
in Hollywood, but nothing is certain here;
outside of the production, nobody's even sure how
much involvement Hamill even had in the process.
But while many fans will be thrilled
to get some answers to those questions,
others might be less than thrilled to return
to the Mandalorian Season 2 finale. Indeed,
while the moment of Luke's triumphant
return garnered much praise from many,
some would have preferred that Disney recast
the role instead of using de-aging technology.
Online Star Wars fans even had a consensus
candidate to fill young Skywalker's Jedi boots:
MCU mainstay Sebastian Stan. Twitter user
@djesson81 summed up the most emphatic
faction of the fandom's thoughts after the
Mandalorian Season 2 finale aired, tweeting:
"Jesus Christ, just use Sebastian Stan for Luke
rather than this janky PS3
[cutscene] looking version we got!"
Of course, it'll be interesting to hear
whether anybody ever considered recasting
Luke for his special appearance in The
Mandalorian — or whether it was de-aging
tech all the way for Jon Favreau and company.
Whether they did or not, though, we're bound
to know for certain when the newest episode
of Disney Gallery hits Disney+ this August.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
"The Mandalorian" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.